the free leads you to the paid if you
have no momentum no traction no clients
then start for free prove your worth and
build momentum give them something they
can't wait to have again and pay for
this time the goal isn't to do free
forever but the free gives you the thing
that you're missing the most which is
momentum in your business and so the guy
that I had on last week is a coach he's
a health coach he wants to help people
make transformations to their health and
I said how are you doing right now well
I have a couple of clients but I'm still
working at a restaurant I want to be
able to leave that so I can focus on
this whole time awesome if you're a
coach what I need to see you is coaching
I need to see you coaching people what
I'd love to see now is an Instagram live
regular show and what do you do on your
Instagram live you bring on people who
need help being coached through a health
transformation because it's one thing to
say I'm a coach and I help people get
these results it's another though to
actually see people change to have you
go live with them one-on-one and help
them bust through their limit beliefs in
our mindset and the issues that they're
dealing with and then they come out on
the other side by the end of the call
feeling hope feeling invigorated feeling
inspired because people will watch that
and say man I want a result like that
they see themselves in the client that
you're helping and they then want it for
themselves
get a mentor hey it's Nina Carmichael
and we made these videos probably
because you're the most ambitious person
in your circle but you know you're
capable of much more and you get that
Push by surround yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best my husband Evan Carmichael and
learn how to get paid when you're
starting out from zero enjoy
now you get two versions one will be
free people
one would be like can you do me I I'll
take it for free
which is great don't say no don't get
discouraged don't get upset you want the
free because the free gives you the
content and so if they're willing to
come on and do live on Instagram with
you for free then you do it
and there'll be other people who say hey
I love what you're doing I need a
radical transformation in my health as
well but I don't want to be on Instagram
I don't want to make it public can I can
I hire you privately
Bingo right that's what we're looking
for that's when you start getting paid
the free leech to the paid whatever it
is that you want to get known for
whatever it is you want to start making
money with show it to me publicly for
free and if other people want it
publicly for free as well then it's a
yes especially at the beginning when you
have no momentum and no clients and you
work in some job that you hate yes for
free yes one you get better at it
because the more you do the better
you'll get and two You're Building
momentum and people start talking about
you
and then you get the people who will see
it and say I want that person I want to
I want to hire that person and any
repeat people they want more they want
coaching session number two it's paid
here's how much it costs the free leads
you to the paid so how can you do it I'm
going to give you a three-step process
that you can follow step number one is
think who can you help who specifically
can you help like who are the people
that you want to help so for me it'd be
entrepreneurs if you are a makeup artist
and you're just doing it for yourself or
you have some job that you hate and you
have no no aspiration of being an
entrepreneur I I might be able to help
you a little bit but it's not my core
audience I want to help entrepreneurs
who are the people specifically that you
want to be helping so in the case of the
guy who was in my Insider's group he
started off yesterday and he was a
transformational coach okay great but
that's that could be anything I transfer
me everybody needs a transformation
everybody the whole world needs a
transformational coach who because if
you can't tell me exactly who it is that
you helped then I can't I can't think of
who I can refer you to you're making it
too difficult on people if you serve
everybody then you serve nobody so who
are you helping he's like well I love
helping people who need a big
transformational change in their health
because that was me awesome now it's
more specific step number two is what
specifically will you do how do you help
are you gonna are you gonna coach me
through a process you're gonna meditate
with me you're going to give me you know
a product that will help me what
specifically will you do and so with my
friend who was in the group he was
saying that he he wants to do coaching
calls he coaches people they don't have
to be face to face it can be anywhere in
the world as long as you can see them
great so that's specifically what you do
you have your methodology you have your
steps makes you seem like an expert and
you kind of know what you're doing right
you create your own methodology say here
is how I can help people get a result
from the problem that they're coming in
with and in Step number three is think
how can you make it public you need them
to get a result you need this specific
person with this problem to come in
you're going to help them you're going
to help them get a result and I want to
see them get a result and then how can
you make it public so that other people
can see it too so that it's not just you
talking about how you had this great
result but it's them in a public forum
so I can if I see them getting a result
I'm going to think I'm just like that
person too
I want to contact you and hire you and
bring you on board my team because I
want for me what you just did to that
person so who can you help what
specifically can you do and then how can
you make it public rule number two learn
how to sell you don't have to be an
extrovert to sell you also don't have to
be a slime ball to sell either all you
need to sell is a vision that you
believe in and a passion to make it come
true and if you don't learn to
effectively sell that Gene this idea
that you have in here that can serve the
world will never come to fruition and
you'll never get the impact that you're
after so I'm here in LA and over the
past two days I've been on the podcast
for Jordan Belfort Wolf of Wall Street
and Jay Abraham who's the legendary
marketing Guru for Tony Robbins and
Damon John and a whole bunch of other
people and I'm on their podcast I'm
telling them that they need to be on
YouTube that they need to get their
message out I want to see them more
heavily invested I want to see their
message reach the world and
five years ago
Evan five years ago would have been too
afraid to humbled to worried that I
might not be perfect that I wouldn't be
able to persuade them to do the thing
and so I wouldn't have tried
and I still have a bit of that in me
when when Jordan Belfort asked me how
good are you like how good at YouTube
are you and the answer that I gave was
within the thought leadership world if
you you want to help entrepreneurs I'm
I'm top three five in the world
even as I say it it feels weird saying
it because the the Canadian or
Carmichael kind of humbleness is pumping
in but it's also true
because when you're talking to somebody
who is not super familiar with what
you're doing they're trying to get in
understand you when I'm talking to
Jordan Belfort and trying to give them
an understanding of what I do and why my
message is so important for him I'm
trying to serve him I'm trying to help
him I want him to win
so The credibility is important backs it
up and me not strongly believing in
myself means that he won't believe in me
either and one of my favorite messages
from Jordan and I told him this at the
beginning of the podcast interview was
sales
is about a transfer of certainty of all
the things I've learned from Jordan
Belfort that is the number one thing
that still Rings true in my head sales
if you want to sell people you want to
persuade them on something again not for
nefarious reasons not to screw somebody
over not just to get their money you
want to persuade them I'm here try to
persuade Jordan trying to persuade Jay
trying to persuade lots of other people
to take their message and put it up on
YouTube to spread it to the world it's
for them right I got frustrated with
Jordan halfway through the interview and
he said why are you frustrated because
he's making it a joke and some and
having fun and he loves having fun on
the show and and it's a more
entertaining show he's way more funny
and entertaining than I am I told him
you're doing this for the audience
because people watch the show I'm doing
this for you like we're here at a
limited time and I want you to win I
want to get this out of my head into
here so you can go take action on it
right
so the ability to sell and persuade is
based off your ability to transfer
certainty
and so when you fully believe in the
thing when you fully believe in a thing
like this is right this is the thing
that has to happen in service in service
for your customer in service for your
audience you have to do this not for me
but because it's the best thing for you
when you fully believe it then you have
to go all in on it now I have an
expression that when I'm 85 sure I'm
100.
when you're 85 sure you don't just act
like you're 100 sure you are 100 sure
why because there's a tendency to hold
on to that 15 that 15 of of Doubt of
insecurity of you don't have the full
picture you don't have all the context
it's always going to be there's a little
bit of you that you're not quite sure if
that's actually going to be the answer
for them or not
if you hedge your opinion if you hedge
your advice
then all they're going to hear is the
Hedge because they don't really want to
do the thing they're afraid of doing
that thing they have systems against
that thing this is something brand new
for them that they don't want to move
Earth to make happen they're going to
hold on to your hedge
if you go to 100 like this is a must
this is absolute certainty this is the
thing you need to do is it's whoever's
more confident wins they sense no
insecurity no no doubt in you
they're gonna have to come on board
that's how you pull them to your side of
the camp and again not in an icky way
not in a slime ball way not in just a
salesy you know scum bucket way in a way
that serves them that helps them if you
can't learn to persuade people to follow
you on your mission and to do the thing
that's actually in their own best
interest if you can't persuade them
they're never going to take the action
and you're never going to hit your big
goals you're never going to have the
impact that you know you can have you
have to learn to persuade and it's a
transfer of certainty so how do you get
certain how do you persuade I'm going to
give you a three-step process that I
think will help number one is understand
what's your big Vision what's the big
Vision what are you trying to do I want
to solve the world's biggest problem
right I want to help people believe in
themselves more I think that's the
biggest thing that holds people back
that you just don't believe in yourself
enough
if you want to talk about that I am
absolutely certain you want to talk
about something else you want to talk
about coffee and if Starbucks beans are
better than some I don't care I got
nothing you could probably walk circles
around me in most things in life
including Starbucks coffee beans but the
fact that the lack of belief is the
number one problem in the world and
here's how to go off and solve it I am
absolutely convinced and certain and I
can pull people in if we're on if we're
talking about give me somebody who
doesn't believe it all in themselves in
the world and anything and we start
hanging out together I'm gonna pull them
in there's no way I'm going to their
Camp there's no way because I'm standing
on the rock right what is your rock what
is your big Vision what is the thing
that you know deep down you know has to
happen because it's in service to the
world and your mission step two is
understand how it can help people get
out of your own head stop being selfish
it's not about you it's not about you
bombing on stage or bombing in a sales
presentation it's about them whenever
I'm about to get on stage and do a
speech I always think I get stressed out
sometimes like oh I gotta I don't want
to disappoint people like disappointing
people is my number one fear I don't
want to let them down and then I think
this is this is not even about me stop
being so selfish Evan this is about them
they're here to see you they're here to
learn they're here to grow they want to
get better it's about them stop being
selfish
right so think about your big mission is
is great it's amazing it'll help you but
it's in service of them when you're
talking to somebody and you're trying to
help them out and you're going from 85
to 100 certainty it's for them keep that
in mind it's not about you even if
you're getting paid it's not about you
it's about you solving a problem for
them and step number three is ask
yourself why must it happen right now
like why now why does it have to happen
right now why does it matter
if you think well they can do it
tomorrow they can do it next week or
they can do it next year guess what it's
never going to happen
there has to be urgency they have to
feel why it's so important immediately
right now for this thing to happen your
sense of urgency and the certainty in
the urgency will draw them in to want to
take some immediate action so paint the
picture and explain why now why why is
this the perfect time well I have to
don't do it right now big consequences
are going to happen right either either
like actual negative things happening or
just lost opportunity and then never be
able to live the life that they want to
live why right now if you do not create
urgency on them nothing is going to
happen so what's your big Vision how is
it going to help other people and then
why must they take action right now also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your more specific plan of action to
make sure you're getting results if you
want the worksheet designed specifically
for this video absolutely for free
there's a link in the description below
go click on it and start building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there rule number three
ignore the opinion of others your fear
of other people's judgment is the single
biggest Factor holding back the success
of your life you want to serve others
humans are built to serve others you
need it it's your purpose but serving
requires someone else and as long as
you're worried about that person's
judgment and opinion of you you will
stay still and never act so you've got
one foot on the brake and one foot on
the gas pushing hard spinning your
wheels and never going anywhere knowing
that you're capable of a lot more but
afraid to take action I don't tell a lot
of stories about my parents they had a
huge impact on my life they're here on
the wall behind me I'm eight or nine
years old and that's them above me
they're really private people so I I
keep the stories that I share about them
to a minimum but one of my favorites are
when I was in school I was in art class
and the teacher told me to do a project
and they said paint a window and so I
painted a window and then I added a
sailboat and I added sunshine and I
paint I had had some curtains and I had
a lot more to the painting and I failed
the assignment because the teacher said
I asked you to paint the window and you
did all this other stuff and so my
parents went into school
later on and said hey uh what was the
assignment that you asked Evan to do and
said well paint the window I was like
well he clearly painted the window I
mean he did what you told him to do and
and they they stood up and became a
shield for me and I was blessed to have
an amazing parents you might have
amazing parents you might not it doesn't
matter either way but
wherever you learn and however you learn
you have to learn it that you need to go
off and express yourself you need to go
off and create the thing that you want
to create even if the rules tell you
that you can't do it even if your
teachers tell you that that's crazy even
if your parents tell you you'll never
make it and they want you to do
something safe and practical you have to
do it because otherwise you're teaching
yourself to play small and that
permeates for life you have ideas you're
a genius you've got Michael Jordan level
Talent or something you should be off
creating amazing things but you're
afraid because of other people's
judgment and as long as that is the
thing that is in the back of your head
that you're not afraid of failing you're
afraid of failing in front of somebody
else you'll sing in the shower but you
won't sing on the street because you're
afraid of what other people are going to
think about you and as long as that is
the reason why you're not taking action
then you lose for life and the goal of
this video is to stamp that out so I've
got a three-step process that I think
will help let's Dive In Step number one
is the boom boom test and that's your
heart when your heart's going boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom right you're
nervous you're afraid you're scared when
your heart's beating boom boom boom that
is go time that means you have to take
action that means you gotta step into it
every time your heart is beating
especially especially especially around
other people's Judgment of you even if
you have no interest in the thing at all
just the fact that you're willing to go
off and do it and risk potential
embarrassment means you have to do it
because you don't want to teach yourself
that you catch yourself being nervous
and plain small
because you're teaching yourself that
you suck and that's not acceptable when
you feel your heart going like this or
your palms sweating or whatever your
sign is that your nervous or afraid you
have to go off and do it now be safe
don't do something stupid obviously
right don't go trying to juggle knives
that are on fire okay there are some
limits but most of the things that
you're afraid of are not that most of
the things that you want to go off and
execute are not I want to juggle flaming
knives the thing that you're afraid of
are other people's opinions of if you
fail or not
you have to stomp it out because this
will haunt you for life and prevent you
from accomplishing the goals you have
for yourself so take the boom boom test
boom boom your heart's going boom boom
that's not play small time that is go
time step number two is the Quincy Jones
rule Quincy Jones legendary music
producer had this one line and it's in
his top tens and I love it where he says
not one drop of myself or it depends on
your acceptance for me and I just I just
remember that anytime I'm worried about
what somebody might think of me I think
back to Quincy Jones I think back to all
the people that I profiled if you want
to be a leader if you want to be an
innovator if you want to be an
entrepreneur you're doing things that
are different right you don't want to
wake up and live the same life as
everybody else but in order to do that
you have to be willing to live a
different life and to be able to face
criticism for living that different life
even if most of the Judgment that's
coming at you is really those people's
insecurities right most people who are
throwing shade at you they don't like
their own life most people don't like
their life and I'd rather attack other
people who have a better life or at
least trying to chase down a better life
than try to do something on their own
the Quincy Jones role and all the people
that I profile look at them study them
see what they went through see what they
struggled with see how many people threw
shade at them and told them they were
not going to make it and the more you
surround yourself with that and know
that that's normal like that's actually
the process that you go through to be a
leader to be an innovator to be an
entrepreneur to be a success to be a
creative
it gives you more confidence so remind
yourself of the Quincy Jones rule that
not one ounce not one drop of your
self-worth comes from somebody else's
opinion of you and step number three is
be the tree I see entrepreneurs and
leaders as trees what does a tree do a
tree breezing carbon dioxide which which
too much of for human is poison like you
get carbon dioxide poisoning it's too
much
but a tree breathes it in and what does
a tree do with that carbon dioxide they
breathe it in they eat it grow from it
and then spits out oxygen positivity for
the world I think that's your role I
think that's your job as an entrepreneur
your job actually is to eat everybody's
judgment eat all the people all the
naysayers that say you can't do this
you're never going to make it happen to
eat it to grow from it and then to spit
out positivity for the world that you
become the example of what's possible
that you become the the person that
people look to and say look what this
person overcame and they did it and then
you're the shining star that other
people look to and you give permission
for other people to chase their dreams
too even the fact that you're willing to
try even if you never make it the fact
that you're will
try will
to go off and bet on themselves so
you're the tree I think that's part of
your role and flipping the mindset of
taking on this negative judgment people
hate me and they think I suck to say
yeah
that's what I'm here for because I'm
going to go off and get my dreams and
I'm going to inspire millions of people
to go up and Chase theirs down as well
be the tree rule number four don't stay
in mediocrity
person that you know you are going to
play small for life look around at your
friends your family the people that you
hang out with what do they want out of
life if you're the one always pushing
them and no one's pushing you guess what
happens you don't get the push that you
need and you stay in mediocrity being
the best in a group of unambitious
people so I just came back from an event
in Florida that I was doing a keynote at
and at the end I challenged an
entrepreneur who showed up to make some
changes on this YouTube channel we met
over dinner I helped him with his
YouTube channel it was him and his
business partner sitting there and I
said bye tomorrow here's what I want you
to do I want you to go in and make sure
you have these things updated and he
said yes I'll do it I said it's
important to do it by tomorrow because
I'm still here I'm still here in the
morning if you need anything you can ask
me face to face while I'm still here
before I fly home to Toronto yes I'll do
it next morning comes around
we show up in a meeting I gotta meet up
happening we got I don't know 30 people
who showed up to to meet with me and I
see him out of the corner of my eye
sitting at the back of the room and I
say hey did you do the thing that I told
you to do
and he said no I didn't do it
I said why what happened
said well we we were doing a lot of
other stuff it's been a full day you
know we had this entire day of of
speaking and meeting people and then so
much information went home we were doing
all this kind of work
okay great but what about the promise
that you made to me to do it and then
his business partner chimes in and said
you know it's actually my fault I told
him Evan's probably not gonna notice
he's not gonna remember don't worry
about it we'll take care of it when we
all fly back home
and so I told him
don't let your business partners low
standards prevent you from moving
forward on the things that you said you
were going to do
staying committed to the thing that you
say you're gonna do your word to
yourself is the whole game forget about
what you just say to other people what
do you do for yourself because we're
often looking for no's we're often
looking for somebody else to give us a
break right he's been working hard and
and he is I know him and I know his
business partner and these guys are not
Slackers they're not Slackers and and I
was poking a little bit at his business
partner saying his low expectations his
low standards but in this situation it
was true
the entrepreneur that I was speaking to
said he was gonna do this thing by
tomorrow morning before he came and went
to my event he would do it
and his business partner says he's not
going to remember don't worry we've
worked too hard already let it go we'll
do it when we get home and they would do
it when they got home I know they would
he's looking for the reason not to do it
when you say you want to hit the gym
when you say you want to hit these
business goals when you say you want to
have this outcome and be proud of the
effort that you put in every day when
you say that you're going to do
something
there will be moments where you want to
let yourself off the hook where you say
I work so hard or I'm so tired or I
deserve a break right this is the
language you use to yourself and so when
that happens you're looking for
affirmations from the people around you
and if you are the most ambitious person
in your friend group if you are the most
ambitious person what's gonna happen
they're gonna say you already work so
hard anyway what are you talking about
yes of course give yourself the break
and it's the exact answer that you're
looking for because you want to give
yourself a break
now if you're proud of your effort maybe
you should take a break but it's not
because somebody with lower standards
gave you the pass it's because you're
proud of the effort that you put in and
so this is where it gets really
dangerous when you are the most
successful the most ambitious person
from the people around you
they're always going to give you a
reason to play smaller
you can't accept it you have to push
through you need to change your
environment I'm going to give you three
ways to do it step number one is collect
good people I like to say I'm in the
business of collecting good people you
want to collect good somebody that you
meet on the on the street at an event
online collect them find ways to stay in
touch follow them on Instagram and on
YouTube and comment on their stuff tell
them sometimes this gets super awkward
I've told people I really like you I
really love your style I really like
everything you're doing
I just want to stay in touch
and maybe that means you're just dming
them when you have questions maybe that
means you're setting something formal up
or you're having a coffee meeting every
month to connect maybe that means you're
asking them you know business questions
when you have them there's a lot of
different ways that the relationship can
take shape and this is where a lot of
people fall down is you expect to have
the answer in your head and when you
don't know what the relationship will
look like you don't go for it because
you don't know what to present you don't
know what to pitch you know what to say
and so you say nothing and that's the
worst case scenario don't do that
tell somebody I love your Vibe I love
the energy how do we stay in touch
and then whatever flows flows
you have to be in the business of
collecting good people you want good
people around you not just for your team
but people who are your peers people who
can be your mentors because when you get
that situation when you say I promised
myself that I would do this tomorrow I
promise myself that before tomorrow
morning this is what happened the people
around you are saying dude what are you
doing let's go not oh you work so hard
you deserve a break no let's go you
promised yourself you would do it come
on
they'd pull you up to be the best
version of you step number two is get
aspirational mentors I love being around
people who've done a lot more than me
this is actually my default I don't
really have people in my life who push
me to be better I don't have too many
people around me say Evan you really
suck at this let's go get better get
better get better I get most of mine
from aspirational mentors from from
Steve Jobs and apgenini and Howard
Schultz and Kanye West the videos that I
put up every single day on my channel
so I had a buddy of mine say I really
love it when you do a David Goggins
video or another one yesterday said I
really love it when you do Kobe Bryant
great if you know that Kobe inspires you
or David inspires you then surround
yourself with him right watch their
YouTube videos watch their interviews
have a Google alert that comes at any
time it says Kobe Bryant interview or
David Goggins interview you get a
notification listen to their podcast if
they have one read their book listen to
their audios write as much as possible
be around that because the more you are
around that they're training you to
think like they think they're pulling
you up to their level even if you never
meet them that's what I try to do with
my channel every day is I need it
selfishly for myself there's people that
I surround myself with daily I want Elon
Musk and Steve Jobs and Oprah Winfrey
and these people pulling me up to make
me better so get yourself some
aspirational mentors the people that you
look up to and say man I wish you could
be like them you can you just have to
think like that and the way to think
like them and act like them how the
mindset of them is to be around them
more often and step number three is have
play bigger triggers I like having
triggers in my environment that forced
me to remind myself of who I am of who I
would like to be of what I'm becoming so
you can have the greatest day of all
time maybe you watch this video and
you're fired up you get motivated say
yes I'm gonna go and do some work
awesome you're gonna wake up tomorrow
and be the person who you used to be
again you wake up tomorrow and it's a
new day every day is a new day and so
you might remember to do something but
chances are you may not and so that's
why having play bigger triggers in your
environment you set them up once and it
reminds you to go off and play a bigger
game so my office there's a bunch of
play bigger triggers here right there's
there's mentors of mine including my
parents who are looking at me every time
I walk into here there's there's the
awards down here which remind me of what
I do that that a million people have
subscribed to my channel nowhere too
it's a crazy number that when I'm coming
to make a video lots of people are
watching it I have my neck braces down
there to remind myself of when I broke
my neck I kept going on my tour I've got
my Doritos here to remind myself that
I'm stronger than these Doritos damn the
Doritos these things are stronger than
me no all I want to do is eat this bag
every single day and standing here is a
reminder of how awesome I am at least
that's what I'm telling myself right
they're all play bigger triggers so
what's in your physical environment
what's the background on your cell phone
what's the background on your desktop
how can you set up your environment once
just with some thoughtful thinking once
but then every time you walk into it it
lifts you up rule number five the last
one before our very special bonus clip
showed up people don't show up for one
of three reasons number one is you're
afraid you're afraid of rejection you're
afraid of failure you're afraid of it
not working out and so you just don't
show up number two is you're not
consistent you show up some days but you
don't show up other days because you
don't have the routines and habits in
place to make you show up consistently
every single day and number three is you
don't want to you don't want to show up
because you don't actually enjoy the
thing that you're about to do you would
rather procrastinate on it because you
don't love it and showing up is more
painful than just sitting around so my
goal today with this video is to help
you bust through these so that you can
show up for life and have the impact
that you want to have so I think the
fear of showing up is actually a good
thing it means that you are doing
something different something outside
your comfort zone something that is that
is not normal that is new and that's
good you want to be pushing the envelope
if there was nothing that you're afraid
to show up to today tomorrow next week
then you're not growing you're not
learning you're not pushing against your
boundaries and comfort zones and so even
today I had to show up but and again it
should be every single day so today I
was procrastinating on sending out an
email to Grant as well as a couple other
people where I'm looking at doing more
collaborations more work on my YouTube
channel and more across pollination
connection to other successful YouTubers
to help the whole entrepreneur YouTube
Community grow right I want to get the
message out there I want to be playing a
bigger game and so I emailed Grant and
emailed four other people with a new
idea that I had so when the idea was
first suggested to me about doing this
and reaching out I had a little bit of
nerves like okay it's gonna require an
ask I might get rejected it may not work
out and I had it scheduled for today
because today was my YouTube day and so
I look at the list today I'm like ah
maybe I should start with one person or
two people or just pick the easy people
and just the fact that I felt that just
the fact that that was one of the
reasons meant I had to go and do five I
had to do a bigger number I had to go
after the harder people I had to do the
people that I thought
may say yes may say no may make me look
bad if they say no and a lot of it is
just head games
the honest truth is Grant's probably not
going to care Grant's probably gonna say
yes like 98 chance he says yes and he
passes on to somebody on his team we
start working together and we create the
collaboration uh one percent chance he
ignores it and one percent chance he
says no
but it's not the logical rational things
that hold us back it's the emotional
fearful things and so what I've trained
myself to do is anytime I feel that that
that oh my God it may not work out then
I have to do it I have to do it I have
just to show myself because the worst
thing you can do is get to the edge of
the cliff and say you're gonna jump and
then not jump It's better not to catch
that you're nervous it's better not to
even come up with the idea to just float
around in ignorance ignorance is bliss
than to catch it and then play small and
so as soon as you catch it I've trained
myself I want you to do the same thing
as soon as you catch it train yourself
to do it even if it doesn't work out
just training yourself that you don't
back down when you are afraid so I'm
going to give you a three-step process
you can follow to help you conquer your
fears to help you show up consistently
every day let's do it number one is tell
yourself that you do scary things one of
the biggest reasons why people don't
Advance their ideas forward is because
it's scary it's scary you're afraid
amazing that is now no longer an
acceptable reason you do scary things
you love scary things you Embrace scary
things you want to do scary things
isn't just a mindset trick it's actually
true you
what's the opposite of scary things the
opposite of scare if you walk through
life and you're never scared of anything
it's not that you're super confident no
it means that you're living inside your
comfort zone it means you're only doing
things that have zero fear that you have
absolute certainty in because you've
done it before
you're bored you're living inside your
bubble and you need to break out because
that means you're photocopying your life
every single day if there's nothing in
your calendar that makes you scared you
hate your life and so pay attention to
the language pay attention to how you
talk to yourself pay attention to when
you feel afraid
and as long as it's not against your
code of ethics or doing something stupid
don't go jump out of an airplane without
a parachute because you're afraid
right most of the things you're afraid
of are not life-threatening
teach yourself that you do scary things
you love scary things and you're not
allowed to use that as an excuse anymore
for not taking action number two is
think what makes you sore what is the
thing that gets you feeling bold alive
confident ready to take action wanting
to show up to life what is it I go
through five s's every morning as part
of my morning routine the versus sing
and then sun and then sore and then
sweat and then scare the most important
part is sore though it's a thing that I
do to make me come alive that makes me
want to soar and so for me what I do is
I think about an entrepreneur that I
helped yesterday and then I pull up my
phone and then I record a message and I
share that to my YouTube stories
Instagram stories Twitter LinkedIn I put
it everywhere
I need to feel like the work that I do
matters right now I'm just talking to a
camera I'm just talking into a camera
right now and and later it's gonna be
edited and it's gonna be thrown up on
YouTube and lots of people are going to
watch the video that's that's crazy it's
hard to imagine because I'm just sitting
here in my office talking into a camera
and so I need to remember that the work
I do has purpose that this matters to
some people right that people rely on my
videos every day as a part of their
routine
and that helps make me soar so I wake up
just like everybody else I'm tired I'm I
don't know what time it is sometimes
even this morning I woke up I didn't
even know what day it was is it the
weekend is it I had no idea right yeah
wake up I'm not coming out of the day
scene yeah oh my gosh let's go right
that's not how anybody wakes up nobody
that's not how Grant Cardone wakes up
Evan Carmichael Tony Robbins no but it's
not how we wake up the difference is the
habits that you set on a daily basis to
demand that success to demand that you
show up
and so what is the thing that helps make
you sore maybe it's remembering the
impact you want to have maybe it's
sharing a message to YouTube to
Instagram to LinkedIn maybe it's doing
an active service maybe it's meditation
maybe it's reading maybe it's watching
these videos what is it that makes you
feel like you want to soar and then
don't randomly hope that it happens
demand that it's part of your morning
routine because if you woke up and did
the thing to make you sore to make you
feel bold confident Unstoppable and you
did that every day for the next year
your life will be dramatically different
you will not recognize the person who
you used to be
the challenge is you're not consistent
in soaring and so I need you to make
that part of your morning routine and
then number three is understand what is
your Michael Jordan Talent what could
you be the greatest in the world at you
could be the greatest the greatest of
all time at something you are but what
is that thing most people are living way
below the potential because they settled
you settled too early you settled
because you were pressured you settled
because you were afraid you settled
because you ran out of time or at least
you felt you did that's not an
acceptable answer anymore you could be
the greatest in the world at something
and if you're procrastinating on
something it's either because you're
afraid of the thing in which case you
need to go and do it because you do
scary you do afraid right back to tip
number one or two you just don't like it
you're procrastinate because you don't
like it and if you continue to do work
that you don't like
you're never going to be the best
because you're going up against people
who love it who love it
who love it
right if you're going up to play
basketball against Michael Jordan you
better love the game as much as he does
or you're gonna lose if it's just a
strategy for you you're gonna lose and
so look at the thing that's in front of
you look at the thing that you are not
showing up for it's for one of those
three reasons either you're afraid to do
it and therefore you must do it or two
you don't have consistent habits in
which case you need to put the thing
that makes you soar into your morning
routine or three you just don't actually
want to do it and stop forcing yourself
to do it go off and find the thing that
you have Michael Jordan level Talent at
the reason why you don't follow through
on your vision is because you don't
trust it enough it makes sense that it's
going to happen but it's not happening
yet people aren't saying yes there's no
momentum there's no money coming in and
you start to wonder who am I to have
this big dream so then there's this
temptation to give up and go do
something else and not follow through on
your vision but you know in the back of
your head you know you know that
eventually for someone it's going to
work out you need to stay on it you need
to follow through otherwise someone else
is going to make money off of your idea
they're gonna make it happen without you
so I look at what I'm trying to do here
with with this Channel with my YouTube
content with my my mission my purpose
I'm trying to solve the world's biggest
problem I want to spread more belief
right the world's biggest problem is
that people don't believe in themselves
enough I think everybody is a genius
everybody has Michael Jordan level
Talent at something they're just not
living it they're not doing it they're
not expressing it and so they end up
living a life that they don't like
knowing that they're capable of more
like this is the problem I am trying to
solve it's one that that I'm never going
to fully solve in my lifetime and I wake
up every day trying to do it and it's
easy to get up and think well there's so
many people trying to do the same thing
there's there's Tony Robbins and there's
all these other people who am I to go
off and do this and I remind myself that
I may not be Tony Robbins I may not ever
have as big an impact I may not sell as
many books as Simon signic I mean I may
never have that big an impact
but I was able to help some people
yeah we've have two million subscribers
across the channels we have 300 million
views across the channels it's having an
impact it's helping people
I can get better I need to get better
but what I'm doing is already having an
impact in helping people so I need to
keep going and that's what I find really
helpful just reminding yourself that
that you matter that the work you do
matters even if it hit one person it
made a difference it matters and so you
have to follow through you have to keep
going because what's what's the
alternative what are you gonna do go
work at some job that you hate that
that's what you're gonna do the rest of
your life you don't want that life and
then you see somebody else start winning
off of the idea that you had just
because they stuck with it they kept
following through a lot of the people
who win aren't the smartest they're not
the the even people who don't have the
biggest Mission or Vision that they just
kept going they started and they kept
going the thing that's missing for most
people is just momentum you don't have
enough momentum you're a genius and
dummies are winning from your idea
because you don't have enough sustained
momentum you have to keep going
and so if you're struggling with that
imposter syndrome is struggling to keep
going with motivation I'm going to give
you a three-step process that I think
will help Step One is Big Y little y
I like using this as a way just to
remember what I'm doing remember why
it's important and have the the mindset
every day to wake up and go to work the
big why is what you're trying to do the
big mission The Impossible Dream the big
Vision the goal that's never going to
happen what is that thing that's your
big why I want to solve the world's
biggest problem never gonna happen and
yet I wake up every day trying to make
it happen that's my big why
sometimes the Big Y is too big right
sometimes it's scary sometimes you look
at that and say I can't do that I mean
if it's never going to happen in your
life why even try right so you might
have some days like that and so then I
look at the little why and the little Y
is the individual person that you helped
it's the comments on the video that I'll
get on this on this video you guys right
you're my little why it's before I
started doing YouTube I was doing
speaking
and people would give me praise after my
event and I feel great but then the next
day I wake up and I feel low again so I
would look at the praise I made this
PowerPoint file and I looked at the
praise every day that people put in and
that kept me going it's my little why
it's like I touched somebody it was
important and so for the days where you
feel like you're Big Y is too big and
never gonna happen and who are you
you're like well I help some people
and even if you don't have lots of
subscribers on YouTube you've helped
somebody
you can always help somebody you can
always help one person today you can
help them just just go to Twitter and do
a search or go to Instagram and do a
search of somebody who's complaining
about a problem that you can help with
and just help them give them advice make
a quick little video to say here's what
you can do to help there you go then
maybe that takes you five minutes to do
you just help somebody that's your
little why so the big why the little y
Big Y your big Vision your mission your
dream your big goal that's getting you
excited to go forward little why when
the Big Y feels too big to remind
yourself that what I do is important
what you do is important that you matter
that you make a difference number two is
trust your bold ideas you need to trust
that your ideas come to you for a reason
an idea came to you for a reason where
did it come from I don't know but it
came to you for a reason and Trust in
them because you have ideas that are
happening all the time in your head
whether you're going on a walk or I get
a lot of ideas in the shower wherever
you're getting your ideas trust that
they came to you for a reason and you
need to see them through you got to do
something about it the biggest thing
again is is lack of momentum
don't worry about it working out don't
worry about the end game don't I don't
how am I going to get to a billion
entrepreneurs how am I going to have
this I don't know don't get stuck on
that that's that's quicksand
that prevents you from moving forward
because there's so many different
options that you want to plan it to get
the Perfection you'll never be perfect
stop trying to make a perfect plan does
not exist move do something trust that
that idea came you for a reason let's go
the idea came you for a reason you gotta
do something about it immediately right
now today because you're gonna wake up
tomorrow a different person and step
number three is study success study
success find the people who've done the
thing that you want to do who've done it
who've had success doing it and I find
it super helpful because one it gives me
the motivation to keep going because
chances are they failed many times they
failed over and over and over again and
then they won right nobody just have an
idea and boom they're a millionaire
overnight right
most of your Heroes they failed more
than you failed and they came from less
than what you were you've already come
from right you have you have more
resources right now than your Heroes did
when they started you just do so that's
inspiring at least for me
and then it also gives you the
strategies what do they do and what can
you do too and so studying success is a
great way to be able to take those ideas
you've got that Vision that you have and
actually turn it into some kind of
action
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome and if you
want to watch Evan's top 10 rules for
Success check out the video next to me I
think you can enjoy continue typically I
will see you there you are where you
consistently think about whether you
think you'll win or lose you're right
it's a challenge I think a lot of us
face we are stuck in our head in our
mind telling ourselves why we can't do
something why we're not good enough